the Earth's poles are warming faster
than any other place on the planet our
earth matters coverage goes now to
antarctica's iceberg alley' aboard a
one-of-a-kind scientific drilling vessel
researchers from around the world on the
joy DS resolution are investigating the
climate history of Antarctica we'll also
take you to the u.s. outpost at Palmer
Station where the scientific support
team is helping American researchers
during the Antarctic winter
[Music]
hi I'm Maureen Remo one of the chief
scientists on this voyage of the joy DS
resolution this is a multinational
scientific organization collaboration
between about 20 nations so you could
think of it like the International Space
Station of the oceans this is a drill
ship you can picture it like if you had
a multi-layer cake and you took a clear
straw and you stuck that straw into the
cake and then you pulled the straw out
and you can see all the layers of the
cake we're drilling the deep sea
sediments that have been dropped by
icebergs over the last few million years
it's because we know so much about how
climate varies naturally that we know
what's happening now isn't natural that
it's caused by human activity look at
the whole thing so there are many
scientists on Antarctica right now and
they're the other half of the puzzle
they're studying what's happening now in
real time on Antarctica hello I am Ken
Heaton and this is Hannah James and we
work at Palmer Station Antarctica that
is funded by the National Science
Foundation it's a really cool thing that
our country does it's just not a lot of
people moment and and we really like
being part of that small group people
who come down here and are out there on
the cutting edge of science helping the
scientists get their work done I think
what's really important for people to
understand is that the ice sheets are
melting the poles are warming faster
than any other place on the planet and
the water goes into the ocean and it
shows up on our doorstep in New York or
California or Florida or Europe or
wherever you are and if people need to
be thinking about this and worrying
about this shows once again we are all
connected you know we don't think we are